the girag and experience i think it
would changed consciousness period i
think human beings would develop a
completely different sense of reality
itself completely different south of our
perspective in the universe
I think it's terms and I didn't mind
expanding I didn't probably took a small
dose how much do I need to take five
grams usually in darkness if you can get
in an isolation tank go that way yeah
don't be a pussy
you're talking about mushrooms and you
haven't gone the big route I haven't no
let your bro you know you've dipped your
toes in the water you haven't jumped
into the ocean can I tell you my
mushroom story
yeah with some friends we went camping
we were doing mushrooms and we're all
standing in this lake in Idaho with some
like redneck families camping all around
us and we're like two gay guys and two
straight GU straight couple and we're
just tripping out of our mind so
mushrooms that were standing it's like
in these fish are nibbling are the hairs
on our legs and we're all like whoa and
then suddenly there's a boat going back
and forth in front of us that has dared
the drug resistance education logo
that's like the police boat that's going
back and forth in front of us and then a
prop airplane comes right at us we're
like standing there and this airplane is
like we see it in the sky it's getting
lower and lower it's pointed right at us
it comes over right at us at the boat
and we were all like we see are you
seeing an airplane and then the airplane
went right over our heads we all shit
ourselves we were terrified we like how
what the fuck it disappeared like right
behind us on this little rise what the
fuck and we ran up there thinking it was
gonna be a plane crash and there is a
runway because we come down to the beach
sideways and along the sand and there
was an airport right there but there was
this moment we're like we're tripping
the fish are eating us the Dare boats
going like this which something is
paranoid and now here comes the plane
for our heads and I haven't done
mushroom sense and maybe that's why yeah
that's probably a bad place to do
mushroom set and setting is one of the
most important things like well where
you were at a boat with a fucking dare
boat going by and a plane fly I mean
you're at a runway we had no idea we're
standing at the foot of a room yeah you
can smoke pot and do jujitsu with no
problem whatsoever
no problem smoke pot and you're very
coordinated well
pot and something drops you catch it
like your reflexes everything they're
all there unless you're not used to it
if you're not used to it all you're
thinking of starting getting high Joey
started making fun of me because we I
forget what we did we Oh I remember we
went to the fucking Sunday brunch at the
House of Blues remember they had that
Gospel Brunch that gospel yeah we all
went over there and we were toasted to
the gills it was like one of the first
weekend's I ever got high and Joey Diaz
like look at this fucking rookie okay I
was going I can't believe a high I'm
right now this is ridiculous I can't I'm
I have to sit here I wasn't used to it
I didn't know how to deal with it but if
I was the same high right now I'd be
fine because I know what that is it's a
it's what you're doing is when you're
too high and you're paranoid and you're
frozen you're frozen cuz you don't know
what it is you don't know what what
comes next with is this gonna get worse
am I gonna get more crazy oh my god how
long is it's gonna last but when you're
used to being high you're like I'm just
high dude relax
everything's fine you know what it is
you know the worst it gets you know the
best it gets you felt the full the full
range of the effects but you were
laughing at me I'll never forget fucking
rookie when you first get high you get
so enjoyably hungry enjoyably like this
simple like a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich it's fucking filet mignon in
your mouth yeah like you either with a
bag of chips
what is your senses right yeah it just
says is it so you don't even breathe you
just chew it like I have a bug giggling
like I love to giggle bro a couple weeks
ago I ate a cookie and I was sitting
there so fucking stoned at 8 o'clock at
night and I kept thinking to myself this
is the same cookie Casey Kasem ate the
week it was
it was the week that he was busy then he
went - no I felt so bad I grew up on
fucking Casey Casey
but then there was traffic when I was
watching the news that name there was
traffic on the 405 and I'm like oh my
god
there's traffic on the 405 Nelson they
said that just cause the traffic was
that the President of Israel was on the
405 so how walk after it down no I kept
thinking about was the President of
Israel knows about these cookies Casey
Kasem a he's coming to LA to get these
cookies that's how I was giggling at the
thought of my thoughts
that's hilarious and I was happy I love
that I love still giggling that's what I
miss the most about being stoned to the
gills going to a diner or laughing at
the waitress just kidding how you doing
boy he just fucking you can't control
yourself I got this all that shit the
simple pleasures a week even before like
I surprised myself that I became a world
champion and kickboxing like I just
wanted to fight to validate my coaching
and I just kept on winning fights oh my
god I guess I'm alright at this but at
the end of the day I'm still the biggest
fan like I you're gonna have to kick me
out of here today I could just keep you
want to look at more fights like I
didn't watch it till the cows come I'm
waiting man yeah it's it's my that's you
know that's why I don't watch other
sports because I think we're in the
coolest sport there's you know what to
do all the sports on the planet are
wrestling no fighting and runners either
run not the be food or running to get
your food either fight not to be food or
fight they're the two most primal things
you can do yeah especially fighting yeah
I mean that's what this I kind of kind
of a it's a Cicero quote on my arm the
best protector of the sheep is the wolf
I believe that some people in their
wolves and some people are sheep you
know people love fighting they're the
wolves they're the protector so you know
and it's kind of like training day to
state you're talking about it takes a
wolf to catch a wolf but like fighting
is dude it's the most primal thing I'm I
still miss that that dude wants to kick
my ass I gotta kick his ass it's it's
the most nerve-wracking it's like
all right so I was a little experimental
when I was a child and teenager after I
lost my sister I saw about 25 or 26
Grateful Dead concerts and I I'll use
this analogy I'd say that um fighting
your first fight if you've never done it
before
it's like taking acid either find
yourself or lose yourself like I've seen
people or the baddest ass person on the
planet they're the best fighter in the
gym and they go to the fight and they
just melt like butter they just can't
you know that's like the trip out you
know and I that's what I love about
fighting you gotta take who you are in
that in the gym and you're a god in
front of 20 people I'll do it in front
of 20,000 people more on a local show do
it in front of 2,200 people it's still I
love that vortex that rush of the
proving ground
yeah real true proving ground an
exposure of truth like nothing else
because that's what I think it's like
I've seen so many people lose themselves
mhm